hello and welcome to Android design in
action the third episode of this awesome
show I'm Roman Nurik your host I'm
broadcasting live from New York City and
we're joined to my right by Nick butcher
coming in live from London hello
so welcome back from your holiday right
man thank you thank you thank you Nicky
it was a quite a quite an awesome
holiday we actually went to San Diego
which was nice and I caught up on the
show that you and Adam did last week it
was quite good very good job so for
those of you that this is I guess your
first time watching Android design in
action is a show where we basically look
at some of the apps that were previously
reviewed in the Friday app clinic
broadcast from Mountain View and we take
a look at them in more detail visually
kind of more from a design standpoint
and we also reimagine them kind of give
them a makeover if you will so today
we're going to look at a few camera apps
specifically camera zoom FX and glimmer
so let's just get right into it and
start with our first app camera zoom FX
so camera zoom FX is basically it's a
camera placement that gives you tons and
tons of additional features it gives you
special effects that you know things
like overlays things like like borders
kind of like hipster filters if you can
see here there's a kind of that effects
button and it also gives you a bunch of
you know customizable settings for your
camera like zoom and and flash and
things like that it also lets you
customize the type of camera you use so
you can use you know or the SEPA shedder
I guess you could use a single shot you
could use kind of like a time-lapse you
could use an interval or like a
countdown things like that
so we had a couple of comments on this
app couple of visual comments and I'll
start in a nickel jumping as well I
guess the first
of comments that I had visually are
basically that there's a lots of a lot
of controls on the screen and you can
see that there's you know some controls
on the left and some controls on the
right and there doesn't seem to be kind
of a strong kind of order or purpose for
the for the placement of these controls
the other thing you can't really see
here but a lot of the assets were blurry
and they weren't optimized for xhdpi
devices and this is something that we
see pretty often and it's something
that's very easy to fix normally and you
know there's really also kind of a mixed
bag of styling there's kind of these
faux 3d skeuomorphic elements on the
right there's these kind of gradient
custom 3d elements on the top right and
then on the left you have kind of
flatter icons so the styling was really
you know kind of intersperse there's
different kinds of styles throughout so
that was one thing we wanted to kind of
look into changing and you'll see in the
next couple of screens as we review
those that there are also different
styles for the different pop-ups and
dialogues that come on also you'll
notice that there is the actually Nick
you wanna say anything about this these
three little dots on the top right the
button of shame the button of shame yeah
so this is for developers you haven't
yet optimized their application to to
run on devices with software navigation
keys and so you get this emulated button
and it's kind of ugly and kind of hard
to hit and doesn't really offer the best
experience many users yeah and any other
thoughts on on camera zoom effects Nick
or shall we jump into the delivery
design yeah I think you know that I
think the two major things for me was
the kind of inconsistent styling which
wasn't really you know the Android holo
type theme that you would expect perhaps
and coupled with just some unclarity
about what the iconography meant and how
to actually use the app I kind of found
that if you just look at the screen
isn't too intuitive how to go about it
so let's see what see what we did with
it okay so let's look at the redesign
and you can see here that most of the
the placement I guess the the general
placement having controls on the left
and the right of the screen we kept but
we did do a couple of things differently
and let me talk through all those
individual points so the first thing is
that we wanted to simplify the the
mental model for users we basically put
camera and camera related settings on
the right so you see all on the right
you see things like you know focus
change the camera you know from front to
back
take a photo settings and then zoom and
then on the Left we just put effects so
everything that is kind of the special
sauce of this app you know the effects
and the cool you know things you can do
to your photos we put on the left so it
simplifies the model for users the other
thing that we did and you'll see this
later on is that we combined the
settings here this kind of shutter type
setting with other camera settings that
were I think under this button we
combined that into a single affordance
here and we'll see an example of that in
a bit
the other thing I wanted to point out is
that we we made the actual shutter
button larger and this is actually
coming from feedback that Ian mentioned
in the app clinic last week is that
basically if you don't have I mean if
you place something very close to a
system button like the home button users
are very likely to hit that button
accidentally and so here what we did was
we made the camera button larger both
horizontally and vertically so the tap
target is much more obvious we also put
up lights out modes that you hide the
the home button the back button in the
recent button so that it kind of doesn't
crowd your your vision and another thing
I'll mention is that we created where we
used more standard iconography
throughout in a standard style we use
the holo holo light star actually holo
dark style on a semi-transparent action
bar so you'll see here that a lot of
these icons are more common icons I do
want to point out that some of these
icons are actually from Android icons
calm by Gunther bear
and couldn't throw his work on the first
episode of the show so a lot of these
icons are from there as well so thanks
good they're the last thing I want to
mention is I guess about actually
there's a caveat here you'll notice that
you know there's there's these action
but or not really action bars there are
these control bars on the left and the
right and they're semi-transparent now
if you've developed a camera app before
you may think oh you know it's not
always the case that I can get a full
screen you know picture a full screen
view so in those cases you know when you
don't have a full screen view there are
a couple of options you can do
letterboxing you can also choose to make
either the left or the right control bar
fully black instead of semi-transparent
and there's lots of other options that
you could you I mean I think in in a
very fancy case you could even kind of
start kind of mirroring the edges of the
screen or mirroring the edges of the
preview around the borders things like
that anyway so that's that's the design
at a glance Nick you have any comments
on the difference between the two yeah I
instantly loved their improvements on
the shutter button because you've
managed to marry the kind of visual
identity of the application and so if
you go to these applications listing on
the Play Store it has these kind of
colorful elements which you've you've
picked out in the shutter button really
really nicely and I'm also a big fan of
using the the overlay style the
semi-transparent kind of button bars as
well because it makes it makes you feel
like the picture is filling the whole
window and which is you know it's a
camera app this is what it's all about
taking a photo so I love the way that
we've extended that photo tip to fill
the edges where possible so that's one
of my to my favorites yeah and like I
mentioned before I mean one of the
hardest things is getting a photo to
fill I actually don't know about Ice
Cream Sandwich or jelly bean if we have
this but I mean one option is you know
if you if you can maybe even kind of
crop the image that you don't see the
top and the bottom or you know there's
lots of different options but that's
just as somebody that's worked on a
camera before it's definitely something
that that comes up like it is kind of
difficult to do but if you can do it
your app can look really great
so let's move on to the next screen in
this next screen you'll notice that we
moved these some of these kind of deeper
nested effects pop-ups again we moved
effects from the right to the left to
simplify the model for users we moved
this kind of panel to the left and so
when you select when you select this
kind of this edit control you see you
see the basically this kind of secondary
set of controls to its right and in the
in the original lab there's actually a
third set so you can imagine having you
know three sets here and at that point
you know you're really kind of thinking
more about the controls and like kind of
finding the thing you want then the
photo so maybe potentially kind of
overlaying on top of the photo maybe
okay but yeah we didn't like go too much
in depth there because at that point
it's really up to the developer what
they want to do and I just want to you
know the interest of time when I switch
over to this screen and this is where
you basically select a shutter type so
you can go from a normal to a timer tool
I think I actually don't know what a
collage does but stable shot lots of
different shutter types and that's
really awesome this is a pretty unique
feature that it has all these different
types but again we decided to move that
into settings so basically you touch
settings and then touch normal shutter
type and select which one you want you
can probably even improve that flow
faster by having a special widget at the
top maybe one that horizontally Scrolls
but that's just you know one way to do
things like that and the reason we did
this was to really just simplify again
really simplify this fairly complex app
so that any types of settings related to
camera go into one place Nick any
parting thoughts for camera zoom effects
yeah I love what you've done with this I
think there's a it's a very powerful app
which lets you do a lot of different
things with images and but having it's
fairly kind of custom UI it means it's
quite hard to take in all those
different options that you can do so I
think using things like the standard
design language of the kind of holo
icons and
standard controls like spinners really
makes it much quicker to pause and
understand what's going on in the applet
and really get down to the functionality
but she won't want to use yeah okay
alright so let's move on to the next
step and the next step is glimmer so
I'll let Nick
go ahead and jump into his thoughts on
glimmer so suppose you miss the athletic
limiter is an application for letting
you access photos on Flickr the photo
sharing website it's a quite a new app
on the market and some people might be
surprised to see is addressing an
Android design in action because overall
I actually really like it it's a really
nice app it's using a lot of the holo
design language and things like
horizontal swiping and so on at present
but as with any kind of Android design
project there's there's one aspect which
you kind of have to consider which I
don't think they've really addressed too
well and that is designing for all
different device variety out there so
I'm actually taking this from it from a
different standpoint than usual and and
we've kind of run this on a 10-inch
device and at on a tablet and looked at
how it comes out and then decided to
apply some more Android design
philosophy on how you could improve
things so moving to the first screen
here if you can make out this is the
first thing you're presented with when
the user installs the application is a
kind of a logon screen it's quite sparse
minimally extremely sparse just as
welcome to glimmer and a log on button
and and I think this is a real missed
opportunity you when a user installs
your application they don't always know
exactly what it does or you know how
high-quality it is and you've got a very
short amount of time to impress them in
fact it's the first thing you show them
is it is a sparse screen with a button
forcing them to login it's almost like
you're kind of throwing your hand out
forth and showing the stop sign and I'm
sure there will be a drop-off here our
number of users just don't even
persevere and carry on and we should be
ashamed because they'll be missing out
on a great application so what we've
done here is we actually reports the
reason we made content come to the fore
and offered a different experience when
you load in so Flickr is about photos
right it's all about showing photos so
the first thing you see when you launch
is that in my opinion should be
rich-rich imagery trickle and exposed to
the fecal interestingness which show
some great great imagery so what we've
done here is we pulled out some images
from that and this is the first thing
you now see so instantly it's engaging
it speaks to what this app is all about
it's all about beautiful photographs and
what's more it offers some functionality
now without logging in so there's a
strong call-to-action there to log in
today with your Flickr account but
alternatively we've got a little hint
there saying you can touch a photo and
so this will take you right into the
core of the app so viewing photos and
seeing comments on the photo so straight
away without logging in or exposing more
content to the users and also we hope
you agree that it looks a little bit
better making taking advantage of the
extra screen real estate available to
you on this larger device yeah and the
one thing I want to point out here Nick
is that you know Nick did a design for
this app and one of the one of the
things that instantly makes your app
look better and we've done this in past
episodes of the show is just using
different weights of Roboto different
parts of our different fonts in that
family so in this case Nick you've used
Roboto thin is it yeah robo I spin and
then regular yeah so using Roboto thin
is I just want to point out it's really
great for really large type so if you
have something like like an initial you
know screen that says you know welcome
or you want to display you know a nice
big piece of text especially on a tablet
you know for for like 48 even 64 72
scale independent pixel sizes Roboto
thin is really awesome cool so let's
move on to the next screen and this is
this is the screen where actually Nick
you want to talk about it's the sets
screen is that right yeah so once you
get into the app once you've logged in
with your favorite cat it offers as
different views on your data so you can
see your photos your sets which is kind
of like collections of your photos and
folders if you will and as well as
seeing groups and things from your
contacts so I've pulled out the sets and
screen here because as you can see on
the tablet you get these kind of
horizontal for full width images which
just really don't
scale up to well to err to a larger
device so we've looked at that and we've
we've applied a different kind of layout
to really take advantage of the real
estate available to you so yeah so I've
just moved over to to the redesign
screen I just want to also point out
regarding those full with widgets
basically anytime you have anything
that's full width on a tablet you have
to you know think twice about it
basically because I mean that's just a
lot of space you know not even for four
lines of text but even photos photos are
very very rich right but when you have
such an awkward aspect ratio like you
know a fixed height and a full width row
you don't really kind of get as much out
of it so yeah so I think you want to
talk about the redesign yes it's a few
things we've done here and firstly we
switched over to a dark theme as well
and as we showed on the login screen the
thinking here is really that as we say
before we want this to be all about the
photos all about the imagery and having
a darker background really lets those
images kind of stand out really makes
them pop so that's the reasoning for
switching over to the fully dark rather
than the the like thing with dark action
bars we saw before I've also moved away
from the horizontal swiping taps the
swiping tabs because that kind of very
long gesture on a tablet device is it's
kind of a bit harder isn't as intuitive
I find for switching between pages of
content and by putting the tabs out
right into the action bar where we have
more space now and this in this this
size it gives you instant access to
switch between those four major views of
your data yeah so the other thing we've
already done there we is we've gone for
a grid view to get more and to make
better use of the real estate and
switched it up from vertical to
horizontal scrolling so as you can see
the images are kind of going off to the
right
so we can scroll horizontally and see
more this greens quite heavily I guess
influenced by the the standard Android
gallery and applications like Google+
but we really hope we've them we've kind
of captured the spirit of Flickr and
married it with like a really rich kind
of viewing
some other minor details that I wanted
to call out as well as he D emphasized
some of the visual information I found
using the glimmer application that there
was a lot of information jumping out at
you competing for my attention from the
photos so for example if you look at the
visual treatment of an individual set
here like a folder we've made it you
know 90% almost about the picture and
then there's a very small kind of
call-out saying the name of the set and
then less important secondary importance
we kind of like de-emphasize the number
of photos in the set so we've used this
kind of relative size and kind of weight
of text to show the relative importance
of the information there so I think this
really makes the photo stand out and
then if you really want to know how many
photos it it's easily accessible but it
doesn't compete to your attention to
things I just want to call out
specifically that I like about the the
changes here Nick is just in terms of
just in terms of padding and font
treatment or text treatment you've given
the text like in this case waves right
that's the title of this set you've
given it slightly more padding around
the table bottom and especially the left
and using you know either four eight or
sixteen dips of padding is usually a
good idea and I think that that just
helps clean it up a bit in the previous
or in the current version of the app
you'll notice that these text labels and
it's very hard to see I apologize for
that but these text labels they're kind
of scrunched over to the side
and kind of squeezed by the top and
bottom borders of that semi-transparent
black box so giving it some more spacing
just helps bring it out ever so slightly
so that it's a little more legible okay
so let's look at the last screen and
this is the this is the photo detail
screen basically when you touch a photo
you jump into this into this screen and
there it's basically a full screen photo
and gives you a couple of actions at the
top Nick do you want to jump into your
analysis yeah you could probably skip
onto the next slide well there's a it's
quite a simple screen really it's
showing you the photo but there's a few
things that I wanted to change about the
screen really firstly I changed over to
using an overlay action but I hope it
comes out in
and screwing it up here so that's
basically I wanted the screen to be all
about the picture I didn't want the
border at the top I wanted to feel like
the photo was the most important thing
if you've used the application as well
you can tap the tap on the main picture
and it will hide the action bar but it
actually has a slightly jarring
animation where it readjusts the size of
the image is doing another layout pass
and so using an overlay action bar well
well and they gave that issue as well
the other thing is if you look at the
title of other folks it was going to
burned onto the photo in the image so
even if you go into the kind of the
viewing mode where you hide the action
bar there the title was still going to
part of the image so I've changed that
kind of remove the glimmer name and from
the action bar crisper I think by this
point you're using the app you have the
icon you kind of know which application
you're in and just replace the title
worthy photo title there yeah absolutely
I think I think providing that kind of
that sense of place of where you are
that's really what what that part of the
action bar is for is to tell you you
know not only you know where you can go
and what you can do but where you are
and so you know the action bar does have
a built in the action bar does have a
built in title and subtitle feature but
in this case Nick has chosen to kind of
use a custom a custom title area that
kind of highlights that it's a certain
photo by you know the author of the
photo okay so tell me what yeah sorry
guys the only last minor thing is I kind
of cleaned up the iconography in the
action bar as well I feel like the
functions it's offering here like
everything sharing these are all quite
quite common iconography so I feel I
felt like it key ended up having it's
just icon rather than I think context
because you still have a long press to
get a a tooltip as it were if you don't
quite understand what's going on but I
just felt like it removed all those
distractions away from the photo then
just simplified yeah absolutely so let's
look at the the other facet of the
screen comment you want to talk about
that name yeah lastly okay tapping on
the comments button or the information
button let's these kind of pop up switch
overlaid the photo kind of obscuring it
other way and I decide just to give that
a bit of a treatment I wanted to carry
on that theme that content is king here
it's all about the photograph so I went
for an overlay style
so if it comes out of this is supposed
to be like a semi-transparent pop-up box
that comes up and it's almost like it's
a bubble mode so you can see here when
you've hit the comment button this panel
will pop up and the idea here is that
that'll stay up so as you kind of keep
one horizontally swiping to the next
photo it's in the cassette that'll stay
up not just kind of switch over simply
if you hit the info icon next to the
idea is it will occupy the same space
you could have the fun animation of it
perhaps rotating around showing you some
information about about a photo and what
we've done here is I feel like having
this overlay information rather than
obscuring pop-up it really takes better
advantage of the screen real estate
available on the tablet because you can
still see a large amount of the image
which is what this is all about and
still and then any comments experience
as well yeah awesome and I especially
like just the treatment of comments and
text so basically within the comment you
have you know the author of the comment
author and you know there's lots of
different things you can do to make text
seen clickable or touchable or
interactive and basically giving it
having it stand out you know giving it
some color is one sign one indication
but another thing you do is you could
potentially use underlines you could
also just have if you choose instead of
having the kind of the quick contacts
you can have the profile icon actually
jumpy there as well if you decide that
quick contact isn't for you but yeah so
it if the author's watching this is also
a subtle hint that this application
already kind of like in the background
checks the new photos from your Flickr
friends I'd love for them to implement a
contact sync adapter so that it joins up
between between contacts and a Flickr
profile so that you can use these quick
contact badges to quickly pivot from you
know other applications into their
Flickr profile and so on and so forth I
love it one of applications it's great
like that yeah basically anytime you
have any sort of social app you
shouldn't do things like contacts
integration you should do things like
you know social stream API integration
that really kind of helps you integrate
even further into the app into the
election so let's move on from from the
redesign of glimmer to a new section of
Android design in action
Android design news and you guys did
cover this last week but we do want to
kind of
help kind of promote some of the awesome
work that's been done in the community
and so this is kind of a section that
we're hoping to do potentially every
week for the show and so let's start
with Android design news in the first
bit of news actually nicked you want to
start with the first bit of news yeah so
I just wanted to highlight an excellent
library wealth and assets which Cyril
mottier
whether green droid Fame has open source
the community he's made some some map
markers for for making map pins which
are very very true natures and a google
map style so these don't actually
shipped with a Maps SDK so these are
some great assets to giving you foods
drugs and customizing from the S oh
thanks thanks very much Cyril fish
sharing these yeah absolutely thank you
sir
the next one is from Smashing Magazine
and Smashing Magazine for those of you
who aren't aware it's a magazine that's
dedicated to teaching the world
basically about different different
aspects of design and also
implementation so if you're a web
developer or an Android developer or
designer and Android designer Smashing
Magazine is a great blog to follow they
often highlight you know some of the
best stuff that's going on in the
industry in this case what they've done
is they've highlighted some mobile
sketching templates so they've actually
released mobile sketching templates for
Android iOS Windows I believe it's also
tablet and phone so if you're if you're
interested in doing some sort of you
know kind of real-world sketching with
real pen and real paper or pencil and
paper and this is definitely something
you should go ahead and download that's
what I used when I was doing the sketch
that's a good nice I'll tell you guys
next is a similar kit from Taylor Ling
who is one of the awesome community
folks that's that's kind of creating
free downloadable assets for the rest of
us it's a it's a GUI sketching kit
basically very similar to the previous
kit but it's you know it's from Taylor
any a thoughts thing yeah there's a nice
I found the the first of Smashing
Magazine may be slightly heavier weight
and I found myself
it was clearly using Taylor's ones that
not quite so heavy to your sketch she
stands out over the frame rather than
smashing one so take a look at them both
see which ones work for you often okay
in other news Android niceties what is
that is that how you pronounce that
niceties I think it's niceties yeah so
Android niceties which is a blog that
where I guess a tumblr blog slash it's a
it's a media outlet I suppose that
highlights awesome
design work in the world of Android
celebrates its first birthday I think
this this blog highlights some of the
most awesome stuff that's coming out of
you know the community you should all
you know try to follow it if you're
interested in in seeing examples of some
of this stuff in action yeah
happy birthday Abhilash I'm probably
murdering your name so it's very coop is
easier to say is your name on Twitter so
yeah keep up the good work we love your
blog yeah absolutely
and I think this is lastly oh yeah
lastly Nikki want to talk about Marie's
awesome redesign of riches out yeah I
think inspired by some of the comments
from the app clinic and some of Robards
redesigns from from last week and Marie
has joined in the spirit of the redesign
movement and has applied the holo
treatments to the ultimate stopwatch
application by our colleague rich
Hyndman so she shared all the assets and
things so it's a great example of you
know taking her before and after short
like like we've done I said oh dude
check it out everything yeah I
especially love the work that she's done
with taking something like a stopwatch
and making it tablet friendly one of the
things that you know that folks
sometimes have trouble with is imagining
you know is my app really useful on a
tablet you know does it make any sense
on a tablet and in general the answer is
yes you know because it's just you know
when a user has both the tablet and the
phone they'll expect that when they jump
to their tablet the the version of the
the Google Play Store you know on their
device that they see on a tablet is
basically gonna be the same thing on the
phone so if they happen to love your app
on a phone and it's just not available
on a tablet or it doesn't look very good
or
it's not really optimized for a tablet
they're kind of gonna you know think
twice about using your app next time
they may use a competitor's app on a
tablet so in this case Murray's just
taking a great you know great step in
taking something that really is more
like a like a square thing like a you
know a stopwatch a clock is really kind
of a square thing right what do you put
in the size of it you know there's a lot
of white space and she's taken that and
kind of merged different parts of the
the phone app into a single screen so
they kind of have a good dash board of
your different new different stop
launches she also you know very
thoroughly aware of the fragments API so
it's a great way of showing how to do
designs for the fragments way of
thinking as well so check it out yeah
okay so that's that's all we have for
the show today tune in next week where
we will cover
I believe travel planning or I think
it's travel planning apps we'll have to
see what the guys in the app clinic go
through which apps they review so we'll
take a crack at some of those and review
them or actually redesign some of the
screens from those apps so thanks for
tuning in as always I'm Roman Nurik and
with me here today was Nick butcher from
London and thanks and hope to see you
next week bye